bonjour pascal terry vous êtes chargé de
l'action éducative et culturelle au
château de maisons laffitte là on va
parler de ce château le tueur est le bon
qui est conçu comme sous le règne de
louis xiii oui fin du règne de louis
xiii
on est dans la première moitié du xviie
siècle le château est terminée vers 1651
puisqu'on sait que la grande fête
d'inauguration du château ses 1651 même
si la mise hors d'eau du bâtiment et
1646 c'est la fin du règne de louis xiii
sauf que louis xiii les morts avant à la
fin il ne le verra pas et pourtant vous
pensez qu'ils seraient reçus ici au
château il ya une très belle cheminée
qui était sculptée en prévision de sa
venue et en son honneur mais il ne la
verra jamais c'est le jeune le roi louis
xiv qui va profiter de cette première
grande réception 1651 il appartient à
keyyo de porc alors ce château a été
construit pour un home run et de
longueuil propriétaires terriens
il a été à la fois il avait deux charges
importantes
d'une part il était haut parleur il a
été magistral au parlement de paris
et puis il était aussi capitaine des
chasses royales ça c'est important parce
que son de son domaine de 330 hectares
est situé entre la scène et la forêt de
saint germain
derrière il a probablement
voir d'abord et alors ce run et de
longueuil donc est un voisin du château
de saint germain et le lien se fait par
la forêt et le roi le jeune roi louis
xiv et la fin du règne de louis xiii
aussi se fait à saint germain en laye
depuis ce qu'il y a eu la fronde et que
le pouvoir royal a quitté le loyer et
elle a ce qui est ce qu'il faut dire
aussi c'est que je vais vous parler de
l'architecte c'est quand même moi ça
alors rené de longueuil confie à
françois mansart le travail de
construire ce château de faire les plans
et d'aménager son domaine en conséquence
donc françois mansart va dire c'est le
plus grand architecte du xviie qui va
être à la charge de cette magnifique
oeuvre comme on le faisait au début du
xviie on va faire un château en pierre
la pierre qui vient de chantilly avec
des règles d'architecturé qu'on appelle
les règles architecture classique on va
faire de la symétrie de la transparence
il ya très peu d'épaisseur dans le
bâtiment ce qui fait que la lumière va
complètement pénétré de part et d'autre
entre le matin et le soir à l'intérieur
de trois personnes c'est complètement
traversant d'ailleurs la grande
perspective qui vient de la forêt de
saint germain
on peut dire qu'elle traverse le château
elle va aller côté scène et en direction
de paris elle va se prolonger par une
grande perspective dans la commune
actuelle de sartrouville qu'ils étaient
tous et aussi des terres qui
appartenaient rhône et de langage au
monde veillées qui étaient aussi des
terres de chasse ton nom étaient des
terres de culture que tu et le
l'architecte françois mansart va aussi à
avoir le plaisir de faire des grandes
toitures en forme de trapèze qui ne sont
pas son invention mais qu'il a
généralisé de telle sorte que maintenant
si vous voyez une maison même
contemporaine avec des toits
trapézoïdaux avec les verts dardoise on
appelle ça des maisons quand ça
absolument ne sais pas s'il est
construit aujourd'hui
et alors est ce qu'on peut dire que vous
font ce château de maisons laffitte va
servir un peu d'exemples pour construire
versailles on dit beaucoup alors on lit
beaucoup parce qu'en fait c'est lors de
ces différentes venues que le jeune roi
louis xiv qui vient pour la première
fois à 13 ans avec sa mère puis à
d'autres occasions il va pas fort
systématiquement dormir mais venir pour
des collations ou des soupes et aux
particuliers va venir aussi avec mazarin
jusqu'à l'âge adulte où il va décider de
construire versailles il va à plusieurs
reprises faire des remarques qu'il veut
un château aussi beau que celui de
maisons à versailles donc on va dire que
versailles
au départ c'est un château qui ressemble
étrangement au château de françois
mansart à maison sur scène
vous remarquerez des maisons sur scène
et non pas les ans la ville parce que le
terme de la fit est liée aux
propriétaires du 19e siècle jacques
lasserre grafite qui parle coureurs de
violence qui est le banquier la filière
acquis le château en 1818 et qui va
faire le lotissement dont qui va vendre
l'essentiel des terrains des 330
hectares du domaine pour en faire des
lots de construction pour des riches
parisiens dont ce sera cette douleur
maisons laffitte sa date de la deuxième
moitié du 19e
on devrait dire le château de maison à
maison laffitte
car la commune va 6/9 ces maisons sur
scène alors vous parlez de versailles
avant ça évidemment il revolving aux
employés alors une histoire beaucoup
plus douloureuses parce que vaux le
vicomte
on pourrait dire pourquoi est-ce que le
château de maisons n'a pas fait ombrage
au roi pour ça mais en fait le roi est
très jeune donc il ne peut que
s'émerveiller ici par contre
vaux-le-vicomte c'est exactement dix ans
après la grande fête de fouquet 6661 et
là le roi peut commencer à se rendre
compte que ça prend des proportions
assez extraordinaire de voir des gens
qui peuvent se payer payer payer
évidemment présent donc mais rené de
longueuil pour rené de longueuil il va
rien se passer parce que locataire n'a
que 13 ans oui donc c'est pas c'est pas
une volonté de se montrer aussi puissant
que le roi de faire ce château alors
évidemment il va y avoir d'autres
d'évolution dans l'histoire c'est le
comte d'artois qui veulent aller un peu
plus tard à mesure que le château va
changer de main essentiellement pendant
130 ans nous entrons 1640 ou la
construction et 1677 1777 donc pendant
130 ans le château reste dans la famille
des longueuil donc venez de longueuil
puisse également ses petits enfants et
arrière petits enfants
la dernière qui va être propriétaire du
château et qui va après décidé de le
vendre va le vendre au comte d'artois
donc on est en 1777 le comte d'artois
l'on peut rappeler c'est le jeune frère
de 10,16 qu'il est le futur
le fait que charles 10 à la restauration
est donc ce qu'on d'artois il achète le
château juste avant la révolution 1777
avec l'idée que versailles c'est énorme
ça prend les pétitions somptueuse la
cour est très imposante et lui il
aimerait bien quelque chose qui soit un
peu plus modeste
un peu plus modeste est un peu un peu
plus
limité il veut faire des réceptions mais
pas des grandes grandes fêtes et surtout
ce qu'il aime beaucoup
c'est le domaine et le chant et le
cheval non pas qu'ils soient cavaliers
mais il est un grand amateur des coûts
risques aux essais et les courses de
chevaux il va les connaître en
angleterre et à l'époque on a de très
belles écuries qui malheureusement ont
été détruites par jacques laffite au
milieu du 19ème et c'est très belles
écuries vont être un vrai attrait pour
le comte d'artois dans sa perspective
d'acheter le château et on va dire donc
c'est un lien avec le cheval aujourd'hui
avant on va continuer à en parler mais
je voudrais qu'on me parle peut-être on
va regarder à son bureau en mamie bien
sûr pascal terry donc nous sommes là
dans la chaufferie droit qui est une
vraie chambre du roi parce qu'il y en a
souvent dans des chapitres clés donc
jamais habité cette vague oui oui
françois mansart a prévu un appartement
pour recevoir le roi avec antichambre
chambre garde-robe un très joli cabinet
au miroir aussi et cette chambre a été
utilisée effectivement pour le jeune roi
louis xiv
donc c'est une vraie chambre royale
par la suite elle ne sera pas réutiliser
parce que le comte d'artois donc il va
racheter le château après il va partir à
cause de la révolution et puis après
quand dira bien être il va être assez
vite roi donc
donc en fait juste après la révolution
on va voir ici au château l'acquisition
du bâtiment par le maréchal lannes
l'époque napoléon donc tout à fait début
19e qui malheureusement va mourir à la
bataille d'essling mais il y aurait eu
quand même le temps pour accueillir
napoléon à plusieurs reprises le premier
pont sur la scène qui relie paris à la
maison sur scène et du napoli est due à
napoléon qui trouvait pas très agréable
d'avoir à traverser la seine par le bac
et les blés québécois par contre le pont
actuel date de la deuxième moitié du 19e
ce que le premier pont était un pont de
bois et après le
le maréchal lannes sa veuve la duchesse
de montebello va garder le château un
certain nombre d'années puis décidé de
le vendre et c'est à ce moment là qu'on
à l'acquisition par le banquier jacques
laffite donc qu'ils achètent
l'intégralité dû domaine les 330
hectares le château les magnifiques
d'écurie mais c'est lui qui va être le
contributeur du grand démantèlement
puisque ça va y avoir le lotissement
donc la plupart des terres vont être
vendus avec un cahier des charges qui
est comme un extrêmement bien fait ce
qui fait que ce lotissement va se faire
dans des belles conditions avec des
grandes parcelles
il fallait maintenir une une très belle
harmonie de l'ensemble
il y a des réserves et aujourd'hui
encore le cahier des charges et existe
puisque on a des réserves qui ne seront
jamais construite dans l'ancien domaine
qu'on appelle le parc de maisons
laffitte c'est un domaine national
aujourd'hui alors ce domaine c'est un
domaine qui est d'une certaine manière
privé mais ouvert au public si vous
habitez dans le domaine du parc de
maisons laffitte vous payer un impôt du
parc mais les allées les réserves sont
accessibles à tout le monde nous parlait
le château a alors eu le château le
château lui il a été racheté par l'état
en 1905
car après jacques laffite il y a eu
plusieurs propriétaires plus ou moins
intéressés enfin plutôt plus intéressés
par la spéculation côte rocheuse
jusqu'à ce qu'en 1904 un projet visait à
lotir l'intégralité de ce qui restait du
terrain jeudi dernier hectares avec des
lots très petit peut-être même une
prévision de détruire le château
ce qui fait que des amis du château on
va dire des se sont regroupés en
association et ont réussi un sauvetage
il est a racheté le château en 1905
donc maintenant le château c'est un
un monument national qui est gérée par
le centre des monuments nationaux qui
est un des établissements publics qui
gère les monuments de france donc il est
ouvert au public
il est ouvert au public tous les jours
sauf le mardi on peut le visiter avec
des audioguides on a des visites guidées
chaque samedi et chaque dimanche l'après
midi une exposition plus ces expositions
plus des ateliers du patrimoine pour les
scolaires pour les publics en difficulté
et puis il est loué pour des réceptions
dont il ya des tournages de films et que
le film est en ce moment par exemple on
a plusieurs épisodes d'un film sur sur
versailles qui est tourné ici pour des
américains mais il ya aussi secret
d'histoire qui vient de tourner à ce
nombre de d'épisodes ici donc
donc voilà c'est un château qui civique
et vivants oui merci à fedimmo pascal
terry